Okay,
let's start it up.
So,
uh,
remember we're talking about configuration,
about handedness,
which was introduced.
The idea was introduced in the context of a tetrahedral carbon,
but you don't need a tetrahedral carbon in order to have handedness.
And an example shows is shown by the oxidation of a sulfide to a sulfoxide.
So let's first talk about the mechanism.
What makes the sulfide reactive?
In this case,
what do you see for an orbital?
It would make the compound on the top left.
Russell.
Pardon me?
Hi,
Homo.
The unshared pair on sulfur.
And how bout the per oxy noticed?
That's not a normal benzoic acid.
It's got two oxygens in a row.
What reactivity does that confer on it,
Devin,
you got an idea?
Two oxygens in a row?
What's going to be unusual in terms of an orbital?
We're looking obviously for a low Lumo.
Okay.
Yeah,
it'll have,
it has unshared pairs,
no doubt.
But we want it to react with the sulfur that has unshared pairs.
So we're looking for a low Lumo.
Anybody got an idea?
Russell Sigma Star,
the oxygen's because oxygen's got a big nuclear charge,
right?
So it's orbitals are low.
Okay.
So we have unshared pair on sulfur,
the Sigma Star on the oxygen,
and we get one of these where we make a bond and break a bond at the same time,
which puts an oxygen onto the sulfur.
And notice that as you said,
Devin,
the oxygen has um,
has unshared pairs,
the n electrons there,
but those won't give stabilization by mixing with an unshared pair on sulfur.
But sulfur is in the next row of the periodic table.
So it has a vacant d orbital that can overlap with that.
So you can get part of partial stabilization there of the unshared pair on
oxygen,
which you could denote by drawing a double bond,
right?
So sometimes draw a double bond to sulfur and we can lose the proton from that.
And we get what's called a sulfoxide.
So there's the mechanism of making a sulfoxide and notice that it's not planar
at the sulfur,
even though the sulfur has only three substituents,
it's not planar.
So it's so it's asymmetric.
It's,
it's a,
it's handed,
it's chiral.
Right.
And obviously you could easily well have reacted the top unshared pair of the
starting material as well as the bottom one.
So when you do the reaction,
you get a Rasamayi to 50,
50 mixture of the self oxides.
Okay.
Now we mentioned uh,
uh Omet Rizal last time.
Here's the chemical structure of a map result.
What will make it reactive?
Anybody got a hint for what might make it reactive?
Elizabeth Scott,
lone pair on nitrogens,
right?
Okay.
Now how one way to discriminate between them is to protonate one of them,
right?
Cause when you do that,
you know,
have this carbon nitrogen double bond,
right?
And the Pi Star will be unusually low because of the positive charge that came
from the Proton.
So acid is the stuff that's going to activate this.
So now you've got a low Lumo and also the high homo from the other unshared pair
on nitrogen.
So Bingo,
you can add just as you would as the nitrogen would add to a CEO,
double bond like that.
And you get this thing with now four bonds to that central carbon protonate
again.
And now this,
this compound has two positive charges.
That's not so great to have a dye cad ion.
So you get rid of it.
You could get rid of it by losing that original Proton,
but there's another proton you can lose just as easily in this way,
right?
So lose the Proton on the nitrogen and then I have those electrons reform the
double bond to carbon and the electrons go out on sulfur and you get this thing.
Now that happens.
Remember it's the acid coming along.
The h plus is what caused this to happen to them at Rizal.
So if you have a ph,
an acid ph between one and three omet resolve will undergo this acid catalyzed
rearrangement with a half life of two minutes.
So in no time at all,
it's converted to this form,
which is the active form.
Now active to what?
Well,
suppose you have an enzyme that has a sulfur on it that's got an unshared pair
of electrons that will make it reactive.
What will make the drug in this form reactive?
Anybody got an idea?
Russell?
I'm going to go to you again because you answered the same question before we
just made this group here.
What's going to make it reactive?
Not Pi Star.
No,
it's the same as oboe,
right?
Sulfurs right below oxygen in it.
So it's Sigma Star.
Oh,
you,
that's what you meant to say.
Sigma Star Essa.
Okay.
So we got that low Lumo and the high homo on the sulfur coming in.
So we can do exactly the same reaction before.
Right?
Make a bond break.
A bond o h minus goes away.
Right?
And we have this thing where we've now formed a covalent bond with the enzyme.
So the enzyme can't do it stuff anymore.
Right?
Because it's tied up.
Okay.
Uh,
so the pump,
the pump,
which takes acid that's made in this,
in the cells that line the stomach and transports the acid into the stomach
doesn't work anymore because that enzyme is what did the trick.
So the pump enzymes inactivated in the flow of Hcl to the stomach is stopped.
Hey.
And in fact,
this is an interesting,
uh,
problem in the design of the drug because,
it's acid that,
that causes this to happen in two minutes to become the active form.
But you don't want it to happen until it gets into the cells that line the
stomach.
So you'll take the pill orally,
it goes into the stomach.
The what problem or you're suffering from when you put the one of you take this
pill,
acid in your stomach.
So Bingo,
it's going to happen in the stomach,
not in the cells,
in the wall of the stomach.
So they have to coat it with something that will make it get through the stomach
first without doing its reaction.
And so they say,
don't grind the pill up right before you take it,
let it get through.
Then it gets into the,
through the liver,
into the blood stream and comes back to the wall of these cells in the stomach
and net.
It gets activated by acid and does this trick and stops the acid from pumping
into the stomach.
So that's the idea.
Okay.
Now should a chiral switch to a single lane?
Angie?
Members.
All BRAILA SAC is Arasor made.
It's a 50 50 mixture or the Ian and tumors enantiomers.
You remember at sulfur?
Not at carbon.
Okay.
Now,
if you go to a single lien anti of her,
will the drug beat twice as good or at least better?
Can anybody see a problem that you would have?
Right?
When something interacts with an enzyme,
the enzyme is a single hand.
So the complex,
the reacting complex between the enzyme and the stuff that you're reacting is
dietary Americ.
If that stuff is handed,
if it's a right or left handed,
the enzyme say is all right handed,
so you have right,
right or right left.
One of them will be better than the other,
right?
So is that going to be something that'll be important here if we make a single
Ian anti more of a map result?
Remember we talked about the lid of mid Ibuprofen before.
We'll a single lien antibe are likely help.
There's an interesting observation about this compound,
the active form that makes it different from the original map result.
Do you see what it is?
Okay.
Incidentally,
notice that's the original OMAP resolve.
All of that mechanism I showed you did was the change that bond from there to
there and the Proton from nitrogen,
the software,
let's go back again.
That's all that happened during the activation,
but it did something crucial with respect to stereo chemistry.
How about that original form?
Was it Kyrell?
Why Angela?
What made it chiral?
Yeah,
it's
like it's either go inside,
right?
The bond,
the oxygen on the sulfur could be either going in or out.
It's,
it's the sulfur is pyramidal.
What happens when we activated it
now it's not chiral anymore.
So this thing is not going to discriminate between anything because it's not
chiral anymore.
Okay.
So this thing is a chiral.
Okay,
so it shouldn't make any difference which hand you're using at this stage now.
So there's no difference after a members all has been activated by acid notice.
It's not activated by an enzyme.
Because if were activated by an enzyme,
then it could discriminate between the two hands and one would be more activated
than the other.
Right?
So that could be a difference.
But that's not true.
It's just acid that does the activation and makes it a chiral.
So at first glance,
one of the things that make no difference at all still,
it could be that one in antitumor is better at getting through the digestive
system and getting back to the stomach in order to do the trick.
So it's still possible.
How could you tell whether it's better or not?
This is getting pretty complicated,
right?
All the different things that would go through to get from here to there.
How would you find out whether it's worth using a single Ian antitumor?
What would you do?
Test it.
How do you do a clinical trial?
Okay,
so you need,
but in order to do that,
you need a single enantiomers in order to do the laboratory in the clinical
testing.
And we're going to talk about that in just a second.
Uh,
but first let's talk just a bit about the economics of this.
These things called Proton pump inhibitors are the newest generation of things
to treat acid reflux.
And here's data from the Wellmark,
which is the Blue Cross Blue Shield of Iowa and South Dakota.
So a pretty small population area,
and this is how many prescriptions they wrote for four prial a sac in the period
from 1999 to 2003 just go,
went up by 250% to two a quarter of a million.
And if you go worldwide,
so 15% of the members of Wellmark get got this stuff as of 2003 and 600 million
worldwide.
That's a big market,
right?
So now here's cost comparison for things that treat acid stomach.
So the first stuff is,
uh,
is tums and Rolaids and saw those are cost three or 4 cents a piece.
Okay?
Then there are these over the counter h two blockers,
like Zantac,
which are now very cheap,
like 37 cents,
but they didn't use to be because they used to be covered by patent,
right?
And where prescription drugs.
Okay.
Then their prescription verbs versions.
You see these h two blockers and Zantac.
One is for prescription costs,
$4 and 27 a piece.
Okay.
But now these proton pump inhibitors come along.
And in 1988 [inaudible] came on the market at $4 and 61 cents of pop.
You take one every day.
Okay.
Uh,
but in 2002 the patent ran out.
So now generic people started selling the generic version of a member's all for
two 76 and astrazeneca,
the manufacturer of [inaudible] said,
we can do better than that.
We've been making this stuff for years.
So we'll make an OTC version and have proctor and gamble sell it.
And so in 2003 they introduced prial Asseco,
TC,
who exactly is exactly the same stuff,
but 79 cents a pill,
right?
Instead,
but you can still get the prescription farm if you want the real thing for $4
and 61 cents a pill,
okay.
But so now you're losing a big market if,
if your pills are costing only something like a,
what one says one sixth or seventh of what they originally cost.
So in 2000 Astrazeneca in introduced Nexium,
which is a single lien antitumor.
Okay.
And now that's four 87 a pill,
right?
And that process to go from the IRS to the s to go from the receiving to a
single lane antitumor.
It's called a chiral switch in the industry to go from a single,
from a Ras animate to a single lead antitumor.
Okay.
Now this was touted within Astrazeneca as the most successful a US launch ever.
And here you can see the graph of how much better it is than Viagara,
Vioxx,
Lipitor,
Celebrex,
and so on.
Over this little more than three year period,
it went up to $8 billion in sales.
Okay.
And you can see that there's been a lot of integration of clinical and
commercial enterprise that at the Astrazeneca,
this is from a website that you can see there in December,
2003 they say the executive director and development brand leader at Astrazeneca
adds the clinical and scientific proficiency as a research gastroenterologists,
as Levine and his staff put together clinical development plans such as
additional indications or align extensions.
They get commercial input at every stage.
Well,
I don't know if you noticed,
I drink water every once in a while because my mouth is dry.
And just before that,
when I learned that the class was going to be filmed this year,
I realized that I'd been suffering from hoarseness since last spring.
And I figured that wouldn't be good for the recording.
So I went to see a doctor to find out if I could do anything about this,
whether there was anything wrong.
Uh,
now,
uh,
there's a,
there's something you can do for this.
And uh,
Nexium has been the most intensively advertise stuff ever,
right?
That was for the public.
This is for doctors.
Okay.
So if you go to that website,
you can see a s a seven part seven scene description of why Nexium is so much
better than anything else.
And what I'd like you to do for a homework problem for Wednesday is to go
through that show and evaluate whether this series shows that Nexium is superior
or not.
Is it worth paying five times as much for a pill or six times as much for a
pill?
Uh,
and now,
uh,
this is the,
FDA approved label for Nexium and it,
and so they did clinical trials just as we said they should do.
Okay.
So here they tried to heal eeros erosive esophogitis.
So what they tested,
you can see is the healing rate for this condition from 40 milligrams of Nexium,
20 milligrams of Nexium.
So that's the singly auntie in two different doses,
doses or that traditional Ometria is all the receiving stuff.
So these were evaluated in patients with mds,
endoscopically diagnosed erosive esophogitis in four multicenter,
double blind randomized studies.
The healing rates after four and eight weeks were evaluated and shown in the
table below.
Now suppose you were in charge of designing this test,
how much of the Rasamayi Omet Rizal so 40 milligrams and 20 milligrams of
Nexium,
but compared to a members all,
how much would you have administered to compare with,
so they're,
they're the singling Auntie,
40 milligrams or 20 milligrams.
How much a members all would you use?
Yeah.
And why
Lucas?
What do you say?
Why?
Between the new stuff.
Okay.
Does everybody agree with Lucas?
Kate?
What would you choose?
But it looks like there's only one.
Okay.
But if you were designing the test,
you'd do 20 and 40.
We'll have an auction here.
Do I hear 80 from anyone?
Rick
80 and 40 why
that way?
So Microsoft is a recipe.
Any 40 of those we get 40 and 20th the accurate.
Okay.
Does everybody see what Rick saying?
If you want the same amount of what is ostensibly the active stuff,
you should have double the amount of my map result.
Now this is what the label says is actually used 20 milligrams.
You when Lucas.
Okay.
Now why?
It's because that's the approved dose for that disease by the,
if that's what the FDA approved.
Right?
But we'll give twice or four times as much of the what we think to be the active
ingredient to the other people in the test.
Okay.
So that's the test.
There were four different tests and this shows it,
but let's summarize it with a graph that will show it,
I think more clearly.
So after four weeks and after eight weeks,
these are what fraction of healing there was with the Ras of mate.
Uh,
which is shown in open figures and the shapes are different.
Studies.
Remember there were four different studies and this is what you get if you use
the single Auntie enantiomers is 20 milligrams,
which remember is twice the dose.
If the,
if that one form is active,
what would you conclude from this?
Okay?
Is it worth paying seven times as much or six times as much?
Okay.
Now,
or you could use 40 milligrams.
Now I think we would probably agree that it's better just eyeballing this thing,
even if we aren't statisticians.
Okay?
So four times the dose does a better job.
Now then this was heavily advertised.
You may have seen these things for the purple pill.
Uh,
so you get this,
uh,
this,
gray haired guy here,
uh,
who says,
if I told you prescription Nexium,
heels,
acid reflux damage better,
you'd want proof and now your doctor has that proof.
Recent medical studies prove Nexium heals better than the other leading
prescription medicine.
Now notice he says prescription medicine.
The OTC stuff isn't the prescription medicine.
So this is a different test.
No wonder they call Nexium the healing purple pill.
So call your doctor today because if left untreated,
the damage could get worse so you can get a purple pill there.
Okay.
This is the test he was referring to,
which can,
which compared SMF Rizal that's Nexium to land soft Rizal.
But again,
it's 40 milligrams versus 30 milligrams.
I don't know anything about the land south resolve,
but that's what they tested anyhow.
But notice incidentally in the acknowledgements,
this study was supported by a grant from Astrazeneca of Wayne,
Pennsylvania.
So these are not completely disinterested people that at least some of them who
are,
who are involved in this study.
And it says,
so call your doctor today to learn about this.
And fortunately,
uh,
we have my doctor here,
Dr. Duffy,
so she's going to give you her perspective on Nexium and I'll map resolved.
Thank you for coming.
That's right Ryan,
thanks for having me.
Let me just steal the microphone.
Oh yeah,
I forgot the microphone.
Here we go.
Well,
I can remember sitting in organic chemistry classes a premed.
I'm wondering why it was I needed to learn how to make paint.
So I,
this is a real treat for me to be here today,
to be able to talk to you about some critical aspects of,
of why it's important to study and do well.
And Professor Mcbride's class.
Sorry.
All right.
I'm,
so,
I'm an otolaryngologist,
seminary nose and throat physician and,
um,
and I work here at Yale.
You,
some of you may recognize me from the health plan.
Um,
and professor McBride did give me permission today to talk a little bit about
his case.
So I'm not going to show you any confidential pictures,
but I may,
I may allude to him here,
uh,
in the top.
So first of all,
the disclosure,
I'm,
I don't have any financial interest in any of the drugs where companies disgust
today.
I'm not on any speaker's bureau.
So in,
in,
in a word,
I don't really have a vested interest in any,
anything shown here today,
but I will discuss them off label or experimental uses of these compounds.
And the opinions presented by me are mine and no one else's.
So,
as you've heard testified here today,
professor McBride,
um,
took pile sec and actually did improve.
Um,
so he sent me an email and was very excited that I could come and speak you all
to dance it by the way.
My symptoms were improved.
Um,
so Pelisek fixes symptoms of Ge reflux disease,
gastroesophageal reflux disease and Lorinda pharyngeal reflux disease,
which is the entity that I treat.
Ge Reflux disease is in the domain primarily of the gastroenterologists.
So I'm going to refer mostly to Lpr today.
Liveringa pharyngeal reflux.
Um,
so we've heard that process works or does it,
we really need to know how is it,
we know these drugs work.
Someone talked about clinical trial sedan.
I'm going to focus a little bit more closely on that because that's,
we,
we rely on these and they come from primarily from Pharma,
a Yale University.
Uh,
my clinic doesn't really have the money to run extensive clinical trials on my
patients.
Sometimes,
um,
some centers are able to do it or you may have a grant to do something that
looks at a drug.
But primarily we're relying on what the pharmaceutical companies tell us in
terms of data.
So about private sector working in him.
All we know is that his symptoms are improved.
They were in his body eating his diet and living his life and taking the drug at
the prescribed depths.
But there are a lot of variables that we may not know about and some of these
variables are what the Pharma companies need to take into account when they're
doing these clinical trials when they're designing them.
Um,
are we taking other patient variables into account?
For example,
diet?
Does he take a large number of herbal supplements we don't know about,
for example,
um,
this could affect the pharmacodynamics.
It could affect the pharmaco kinetics of the drug in his body.
Did he take the prescribed medication on an empty stomach as it's as it's
supposed to be taken so that the acid will activate it early?
In other words,
was he compliant?
And these are all things that I need to be taking into account when I prescribe
a drug to a patient.
For example,
you know,
these studies are done in patient populations,
but they may have been done on the west coast.
They may have been done in China.
Is that patient population representative of my patient population.
So when they're designing these trials,
they try to control for as many patient individual variables as possible.
In addition,
these studies have to be statistically sound because biostatistics drive these
clinical trials and they're designed so that if differences are actually
observed between pilot sack and a and a placebo or [inaudible] sec versus these
of members all,
um,
we have to be able to determine with reasonable certainty if these differences
are real or if they're due to just chance alone.
So that's where bio statistics comes in and it's,
I submit and I think professor McBride who helped me write some of these
probably also feels that there is some duty on the part,
not only of the manufacturers,
but have a academic institutions who are also running their own clinical trials
to actually design the studies.
So that,
so that it's easy to understand the data are there and they're very clear so
that they can make also very legitimate head to head marketing comparisons
between competitor compounds.
Um,
so I think this is very important as a physician,
I feel that I have a duty to really evaluate the literature critically.
Sometimes I actually need to go back and pull the studies.
I can look at the package insert for these drugs,
but how do I know?
How can I actually believe it?
So sometimes I actually go back and I'll,
I'll pull the study off pub med and,
and read it.
Um,
and we have to be able to ascertain the validity of the research that supports
our choices as clinicians.
There's a lot of marketing out there as we heard.
There's a lot of money to be made off these compounds.
And I think I'm going to also propose today,
um,
that we as a society,
we as patients,
um,
we as members of a society,
perhaps the society who may one day have a single payer healthcare system.
We need to be educated also.
And this information is available.
It's available on the web.
You've already seen some of it from professor McBride this morning,
but this website is a fantastic resource.
If you have a question about any medication you're taking,
um,
you want to look at the chemical compound of it,
the chemical structure and how they designed it,
how they make it,
how it's marketed,
how it's distributed.
Um,
all of this is available on the website so you can just plug in the drug that
you're taking or the drug of interest.
And that information's all there.
It's,
it's public domain,
so I'm so use that as a resource,
but,
but direct to patient marketing is,
is,
can be really effective.
And this is also referred to as direct to consumer marketing.
Uh,
you saw some of it in the earlier slides,
but all you have to do is turn on the evening news and,
and these,
uh,
these ads are there,
right?
Every time there's a commercial break,
you see some happy person walking around and talking about this drug and you
just hear the drug name.
You don't hear anything more about it.
You may not hear anything about the studies.
Um,
but it can be very effective.
So I think we need to,
we need to look critically at some of the claims and we need to think,
is this really actually the right thing for me to be taken?
So my specialty,
so back to our clinical model,
um,
my specialty is otolaryngology.
Um,
I'm focusing on the larynx with Lorraine Parent Geo Reflux.
The larynx is the,
the voice box.
It's your,
where your vocal chords are and it's what we use when we're speaking.
Um,
ear,
nose and throat is another name for my specialty,
but we're talking about Lorena pharyngeal reflux,
which is reflux acid reflux.
That primarily affects the voice box.
It's underdiagnosed,
it's also a significant source of more ability and decreased quality of life.
Hoarseness,
uh,
feeling like you have a frog in your throat,
sore throat,
um,
and,
and it's a frequently associated with other forms of reflux disease like Ge
reflux disease,
gastroesophageal reflux disease.
So it's a public health problem.
And,
uh,
this is a very busy slide,
but just,
just to point out some statistics that up to 10% of patients who present to the
ENT practice for any reason may actually have symptoms or findings related to
Lpr living a pharyngeal reflux.
It's also increasingly recognized as a problem that can be associated with non
allergic asthma.
And a great number of these patients also present with a history of acid reflux
from other source,
from uh,
where their symptoms are coming from other sources such as,
such as the Esophagus for example.
So reflux is a very big problem.
I see a lot of patients,
it's estimated that up to 40% of the adult population in this country,
you may have reflux and some steady state even more.
So there's a lot of money to be made.
What is its treatment in the year 2008.
What we're doing is we're treating this with Proton pump inhibitors.
But I have to also,
um,
uh,
put in a disclaimer that there was a recent Meta analysis within the last couple
of years looking critically at the literature and a,
at a number of different studies that evaluated about 10 different studies.
And there's also a significant placebo effect here.
So,
so the jury's not completely out,
but there are plenty of studies in my literature that support it to use for the
treatment of Lpr.
I'm not going to go into all that today.
Um,
but the reality is the Ppis or FDA FDA approved,
they're out there,
they're easy to get.
All you have to do prep practically is ask your physician for a prescription.
So what are we trying to target?
Here is a reasonably good looking lyrics.
So these are the vocal cords.
This is the anterior portion.
This is the posterior portion back where your esophagus is.
And there's left and right.
So I'm,
this is what I see when I'm looking with a scope.
I'd pass it very carefully through the nose and we get a very nice look at the
larynx.
And this is a patient with moderately severe laryngeal pharyngeal reflux.
You can see that there's a lot of swelling here compared to these other
pictures.
This area back here is all beefed up and this area down here also looks quite
red.
And so this is what we're treating with these proton pump inhibitors.
And we're hoping to take a patient that looks like this and turn their larynx
into something more that looks like this normal larynx.
You can see the sharpen the edges here.
So,
so data's out there.
We can follow this clinically.
And that's,
that's usually what we do.
So now the reality when you're considering these drugs that,
uh,
that are being developed,
as we're hearing about today and being prescribed,
is it really only about a one in a thousand of these compounds that enter,
enter preclinical testing?
We'll actually make it to human testing,
what we call clinical trials.
And out of these,
only about a fifth may actually become a be deemed safe and effective enough by
the FDA to gain FDA approval.
FDA approval is the holy grail.
And,
uh,
for,
for a pharmaceutical company and interested in developing drugs and getting
these drugs onto the market without FDA approval,
they can't market the drug without FDA approval.
They can't put out ads on the evening news.
So,
so this is an,
uh,
an example of one of those documents is available on the,
on the website that I showed you.
And this is the approval letter for pilot tech OTC,
which came out in 2003.
It was written to proctor and gamble by the FDA.
And I just want to point out this area down here.
This is an approval letter for this drug given it this dose used for this
indication.
So the very,
very specific the drug companies can't,
they're not allowed to market.
Uh,
it's used for other indications.
Um,
but,
uh,
but this is really,
really important information for the company in order to be able to put this out
and actually start to see some return on their investment for research and
development.
So again,
I just want to point out this is from Edwards,
all 20 milligrams for the treatment of frequent heartburn.
Now here's some information that you saw a different form of this earlier.
Um,
ease mappers all also,
uh,
has approval by the FDA for a number of different indications but also for the
treatment of Ge reflux disease.
And,
um,
what I want to point out here is that in the design of these clinical trials,
they look very carefully,
strategically at how can we show that our drug is better than the competitors?
So clinical trials when they're designing,
these are generally broken down into three phases.
Phase one,
two,
and three.
We have phase four,
which usually occurs after the FDA has given approval for,
uh,
for a compound phase one that's used in healthy volunteers.
The end point is really safety.
They want to know what are the side effects?
Is this a drug that we can actually give to the public.
And uh,
it also,
they also use a lot of studies to determine and metabolism and excretion of the
drug at this point in development.
And these are usually smaller studies.
They usually only need anywhere from 20 to a hundred patients for these.
And then once they pass into phase one,
oh,
sorry,
let me,
let me see a stage just a little bit about safety.
Some of the,
um,
side effects of in,
in the industry they call these adverse events.
This is a terminology that the FDA uses as well.
And it really is just something to mean aside effects.
Somebody had some,
something that was out of the ordinary and they happen to be taking the drug.
So you have to at least consider that may have been considered by the,
it may have been caused by the drug,
a serious adverse event would have led to some sort of damage to the patient or
extended care such as hospitalization or surgery.
And,
and these aes adverse events need to be reported to the FDA during the clinical
trials.
So they're watched very carefully and they can't proceed through to the next
phase of clinical studies.
If there are too many adverse events or for example,
if they have deaths that there's usually a tend to raise really big red flags.
And again,
all this information's available on that FDA websites.
So if you want to see how a drug was developed and what adverse events that
occurred during it's development,
you can see that they're,
for the most part,
there's a lot of internal stuff that's not going to be on there.
But for the most part,
they have to report these Aes to the,
uh,
to the FDA as they're going along.
In phase two,
they're looking for F,
uh,
effectiveness or efficacy.
Um,
the preliminary data generated a generally is for effectiveness of the compound
for a particular disease or a condition.
So this is where we start to get into specifics about which dose of a member's
on Megan and choose,
if I'm going to compare this to Easten that resolve,
um,
they can compare it also to placebo.
They can compare it to a different drug.
And again,
they're looking at adverse events.
They're looking at safety,
but they're also starting to now look,
am I actually targeting the disease?
The study sizes are usually bigger.
And then finally,
if it gets passed phase two,
you can get to phase three.
And if anybody watches the stock market looking at,
you know,
drug companies or biotech companies,
uh,
phase three is where things really,
you'll hear about this.
You know,
when Wall Street,
here's a whisper that a drug's not going to make it through phase three studies
or it may not get FDA approval.
You can tank the prices of stocks.
It's really quite remarkable to watch as a clinician because,
um,
you know,
again,
I don't really have any vested interest in any particular company.
Um,
but I just find it fascinating that even just the suggestion,
uh,
will actually impact things economically.
So,
so importantly,
so here again,
we continue to look at safety and effectiveness.
Um,
we may study different patient populations.
They may look abroad to do some of these studies.
India is a,
is a place where a lot of studies are being done these days.
Eastern Europe as well.
They may look at different dosages and they may combine this with other drugs.
These are usually very large studies.
By this time they've gotten to,
they want to see clinical differences that are so subtle that they have to have
very large numbers of patients to make this statistically sound.
So,
um,
they cost these studies cost millions and millions of dollars to,
so these companies are very,
very invested.
They want to make sure that they get return on their investment.
And then phase four a occurs after the FDA has approved a drug.
Um,
these are postmarketing study commitments and these are commitments by the
sponsor,
the person actually doing the studies and marketing the drug and selling it,
that they will provide additional information to the FDA about the product
safety efficacy or perhaps it's optimal use.
And more recently we're hearing about phase zero trials in the cancer research
literature.
My area of research is in cancer and,
and phase zero trials,
um,
our exploratory first in human trials.
So these are designed to speed up development of promising agents.
As we know,
cancer is a very big problem.
In this country,
especially with the population aging and,
and it can kill very quickly.
So these,
these trials are designed to establish very early on whether an agent behaves in
human subjects differently than it was expected from the preclinical studies.
And that does happen sometimes.
So you can imagine if you spent months and months planning a phase one trial
only to find out when you put it into humans that it reacts.
It doesn't behave the way you expected based on how it looked in mice.
You can lose a lot of money and there's a,
you lose a lot of momentum.
So these phase zero trials are being put more and more,
uh,
into,
into play.
So back to our clinical model.
So some of the studies that we already heard about from professor McBride were a
to determine whether these drugs actually worked in patients with reflux or not.
So A,
and I'm not showing all the studies by the way,
I just have to disclose that I,
I'm only showing you a few studies just to demonstrate what type of data I have
to actually take into consideration as a clinician when I'm looking critically
at how the studies were done,
whether I think the drugs actually gonna be helpful for my patient or not.
So,
um,
this was in a,
in a group of patients,
that particular patient population with their already established erosive
esophogitis sounds pretty bad.
It's pretty uncomfortable.
Um,
and they,
they studied these patients with ease and Metrosol Ana members all at at similar
doses with similar numbers of patients in both arms.
They found no statistically significant difference in the,
uh,
in the symptoms of heartburn sustained resolution of heartburn symptoms in this
group of patients.
Now if you read the ease of members all package insert,
they state that they chose a members all 20 as the competitor dose because it's
the FDA approved dose for this indication,
which it is.
So that went to the [inaudible] package insert defined that they did look at 40
milligrams when they were looking at these types of symptoms.
They found that there was really no improve and no benefit to using the higher
devs.
So they went with the lower dose when they went for FDA approval.
So that's I think partly why they chose 20 milligrams.
And then also if you look more closely,
there's also they lose some linearity between plasma concentration versus area
under the curve,
which is plasma concentration in the patient over time.
So it becomes less and less predictable as you go up on the dose.
How much drug is actually being seen physiologically for the patient.
Um,
so,
so once they get out of that predictable linearity,
um,
things become a little bit iffy in,
you could potentially get into adverse effects.
So I think that's part of the logic for why they chose that.
But you know,
again,
I'm not trying to make a,
an exhaustive argument for which,
what should have been done or what,
you know,
against what was done.
Just to give you some idea for what we have to deal with,
uh,
as clinicians.
So then finally,
these are the,
some of the three studies that professor McBride has already alluded to showing
that there are variable results.
This one,
she had a definite statistically significant improvement in healing and
regressive esophogitis for Isa mappers all over any to over any dose of visa
members all over the map result.
Um,
but two other studies actually said that there was no difference.
So there's another bigger study as well that's not included here for the next,
oh,
I'm sorry.
Yeah,
there it is.
Okay.
Yeah.
So,
so yeah,
you know,
you just kind of have to look at the literature and say,
okay,
I'm convinced.
I'm not convinced.
Um,
I don't know that there's any right or wrong,
but the FDA also has a role to play here and they,
they,
um,
they really vet these studies quite well and they're not allowed to market if
they don't feel that if they have,
FDA doesn't feel that there's sufficient evidence there to support it.
So in,
in my patient population who have,
uh,
Lpr,
a large number of these patients have,
uh,
have heartburn.
They may or may not be treated for the heartburn already.
I may be the first physician they see.
And,
and I may say,
well,
do you also have heartburn symptoms?
You know,
that would,
those would be GE reflux type of symptoms.
So I can end up treating both of those if I put my patient on one of these PPIs
for Lorena pharyngeal reflux.
So if I've just told you that these drugs are approved for a specific
indication,
maybe at a specific dose,
um,
how has it,
I'm able to use it for something that's not really even approved for.
And this is where we get into off label use of drugs.
So once a drug is approved by the FDA for any indication,
I as a clinician can write it as a prescription for another indication.
Um,
but the FDA has put out these guidelines such that good medical practice in the
best interest of the patients should prevail here so that we're using legally
available drugs.
It's an important term according to the apps.
And devices.
Um,
according to my best knowledge and judgement as a clinician,
if we use a product for an indication that's not in the approved labeling,
I have the responsibility to be willing,
informed about the product to basis use on from scientific rationale and on
sound medical evidence.
Now in my literature,
there's a lot of sound medical evidence supporting the use for Ppis in Loring a
pharyngeal reflux.
But I just also,
yeah,
but you say that you haven't responded,
it's not underlined there.
Say there's a responsibility to maintain records of the products use to the
fence cause anyone come around and collect those records?
I try to make something of them.
I've never been contacted by anybody.
Um,
our,
our people pretty conscientious about doing that.
I think that we're conscientious about die about.
I'm recording whether there've been side effects,
um,
you know,
at the given dose we were conscientious about recording whether there's been
improvement in the symptoms.
Um,
but you know,
I don't,
I don't have a detailed questionnaire in general.
So yeah,
take it as one would think that this could be sort of like a wiki that,
that even though you can't afford to do a big study,
that if you can collect enough observations,
you could make something out of it.
We could,
we could,
but then you're into experimenting,
uh,
on,
you know,
if you're doing it with,
with the intention of actually showing or disproving a hypothesis really to
maintain.
We do at new,
I agree with that.
I agree,
but,
but we're not really,
we're not really obligated to submit to an IRB.
If we were,
if we were doing it with the intention of definitely showing a difference one
way or another,
then you then that would be considered an experiment.
So I would be obligated to run that through the Institutional Review Board,
which is there for the protection of human subjects and make sure that any
studies that we're designing are,
are legitimate,
that are ethical,
that the patient has been given the opportunity to ask questions they can
refuse,
they can drop out of a study.
So,
but they're all important issues that I think would be in the realm of,
you know,
at that point actual experimentation.
But it's a really important,
uh,
it's an important point,
but we can't use these drugs for off label marketing uses.
Now the drug companies importantly are not allowed to market.
They're not allowed to advertise for off label uses of compounds.
Okay.
So again,
I have a duty as a physician,
do you evaluate this literature critically and really be able to validate or
ascertain the validity of the research that supports my choices?
So just a very quick word about marketing.
Um,
as I mentioned,
my research areas in oncology,
I've been involved in some clinical trials with oncologic drugs for head and
neck cancer.
Um,
and I get these emails all the time at marketing is really big deal when it
comes to these compounds.
Um,
and just to give you an idea,
this one in particular is about,
you know,
how do you market your oncology strategy,
your oncology products?
And this is an actual meeting that too,
which I was invited.
And you know,
one of the teasers here is that in such a crowded and competitive market,
the ability to differentiate,
differentiate your product has never been more important.
So this just gives you some idea of,
you know,
what the thought process is and what the general culture is.
Um,
and,
and this is again a wordy slide,
but just to point out,
and this comes from nature news,
it's fairly recent.
That industry is really starting to shift attention now to other areas.
So cardiovascular drugs,
which cardiovascular disease is really the foremost killer,
um,
in,
in our country right now,
but they're really shifting their attention now to two drugs with perhaps they
can make,
you know,
another blockbuster drug.
And that's,
that's usually always,
uh,
what the impetus is return on investment.
So oncology,
drugs,
immunology,
uh,
which you know,
would be something from rheumatoid arthritis for example,
and neurology are going to be very,
very big focus of attention of Pharma industry.
So as you watch the evening news or whichever channel you might be tuning into,
um,
you will be hearing a lot more about this and all that.
I think a lot more directive to patient marketing is going to take place.
So,
um,
again,
this has been a lot of fun for me to participate in that.
And I,
I thank professor McBride also for stimulating me to think a little bit more
deeply about Proton pump inhibitors and how is
okay [inaudible]
I'd be happy to try to field any questions as long as they're not too hard.
Yeah.
Yep.
Side of things.
Right.
So the question is,
um,
from you said you're an international student,
right?
So,
so she's noted when,
when these,
when these ads come on TV that there's a very long disclaimer afterwards about
the side effects and,
and two,
I'm not actually an expert on how the marketing of these drugs is done.
Um,
I'm going to speculate here,
but I'm pretty confident that this is a correct,
that the FDA mandates that they put that out there.
So if you're gonna make a claim about a,
a compound and how great it is,
you also better tell the other side of the story.
You better tell them,
listen,
we might fix your reflux,
but you're going to get diarrhea.
You know,
and,
and it's kind of funny actually,
cause if you,
if you look at these,
you say,
okay,
I'm going to take that drug to get it fixed,
my runny nose,
but I'm going to get diarrhea and muscle pains and all these other things.
So,
you know,
it really,
I think the,
it's probably mandated by the FDA.
Um,
and the,
and the FCC also,
um,
may have something to do with that,
but,
um,
that would be my speculation.
Yes.
Studies.
Yeah.
Right.
And then we wonder as consumers,
is this safe?
If I'm going to keep taking this drug for years and years,
am I say if we're,
um,
you know,
or my progeny going to be safe.
It's a good question.
Um,
and,
and that's where some of these phase four studies,
they're called postmarketing studies come in.
Um,
I was involved with one clinical trial where a phase four study actually was
mandated.
Um,
and so for years afterwards,
that drug company had to continue to pour resources into contacting patients who
had taken the drug.
Are you still taking?
And if you're still taking it,
what side effects are you having?
So,
so those are mandated on some level and the FDA really plays the key role there.
And,
um,
that's been my experience,
but,
but it definitely raises questions and the Vioxx trials just was devastating for
Merck.
Um,
and I think a lot,
you know,
they didn't see a lot of that coming.
So,
um,
I think for the Pharma companies,
correct me if I'm wrong,
you may have more insights.
It's probably a,
it's a decision that they have to wait,
you know,
how much resources are they going to continue to pour in?
Um,
and that would,
you know,
on paper it would take away from their profits.
So I'm sure there's a lot of internal debate about it.
Um,
but yeah,
that's,
that's where it was.
You know,
we're thankful that we have the FDA looking at a lot of countries don't have an
organization such as the FDA.
You can market anything you want for almost any indication and whatever does is
goes.
So,
you know,
we're,
I think we're very fortunate in that respect.
I'm going to turn the mic over.
Oh,
sorry,
I'm sorry.
Cases
use it is actually for something that has a bigger patient population so you can
potentially make more money.
Also believes this can be advertised.
How do this doctors find out?
Say the question is if,
if an off label use,
if if an off label use for a drug can't be advertised with a company,
how do I,
how do I as a physician here about it?
Um,
I would hear about it from other clinical trials that were done mid,
maybe have,
may have been supported by the company.
So,
um,
as we saw an example of earlier,
but um,
I look for a,
for literature within my field,
so for luring a pharyngeal reflux is a perfect example of that.
It works pretty well for this drug,
but you do have to take it for a longer time period and sometimes you actually
have to take it for higher doses than is recommended for GE reflux alone.
Um,
but it works pretty well.
And I hear patients all the time say that it works.
It works.
I have other patients who say it doesn't work.
Um,
so,
so yeah,
we,
I mean we,
we just have to look at our own literature.
There are smaller studies.
They may have 50,
70 patients.
Um,
but you know,
an,
an academic institution,
somebody who with an interest in that particular area may run their own steady
because they want that information.
The information's not out there.
So,
so we,
we look for,
we look for good solid data to help guide our choices that way.
Huh?
[inaudible]
use [inaudible] there side effects.
Uh,
okay.
I'll give you,
oh,
how?
Yeah,
there was.
So when I,
I don't,
I don't really have any drugs I can use that for.
Um,
but there's one,
there's one drug in my field.
Um,
botox for example,
botox was being used,
uh,
to help,
weaken the vocal cords.
Okay.
Uh,
it's been used for that for years and patients who have speech problems,
um,
and don't have good control over their vocal cords and the function.
So you can,
you can use botox injections.
Then botox injections came along for use in the face.
And you know,
you read about this on page six all the time.
It's hilarious.
But,
um,
but,
but what they've also noticed,
um,
was that migraine headaches got a lot better.
So you can use that.
You can use botox to treat migraine headaches.
And there are actually our phase three trials going on right now by a colleague
of mine down in Manhattan,
um,
looking at exactly that question.
Um,
so yeah,
you can use them,
uh,
for,
you can take advantage of some of these side effects.
Um,
but I don't know of any specific negative side effects,
uh,
that were used,
but that just happened to you.
You may see some beneficial positive side effects that the Pharma companies
didn't even know existed.
You know,
they didn't even target that.
So,
so,
so we continued it.
So that's where it's important to do clinical trials as a,
as a clinician.
So I'm involved in clinical trials as well,
and that's sort of an ongoing duty,
I think.
Um,
you know,
certainly being an academic institution that we need to also an important role.
Okay,
thanks.
So if you have a few more questions,
come on up.
Yeah,
I'm sure you have to get back to your practice,
but the time's up now and thanks again,
Dr. Duffy.
[inaudible].